[Music]
in 479 BC when Persian soldiers besieged
the Greek city of Potidaea the tide
retreated much farther than usual
leaving a convenient invasion route but
this wasn't a stroke of luck before they
had crossed half way the water returned
in a wave higher than anyone had ever
seen
drowning the attackers the potidaeans
believed they had been saved by the
wrath of Poseidon
but what really saved them was likely
the same phenomenon that has destroyed
countless others a tsunami
although tsunamis are commonly known as
tidal waves they're actually unrelated
to the tidal activity caused by the
gravitational forces of the Sun and Moon
in many ways tsunamis are just larger
versions of regular waves they have a
trough and a crest and consists not of
moving water but the movement of energy
through water the difference is in where
this energy comes from for normal ocean
waves it comes from wind because this
only affects the surface the waves are
limited in size and speed but tsunamis
are caused by energy originating
underwater from a volcanic eruption a
submarine landslide or most commonly an
earthquake on the ocean floor caused
when the tectonic plates of the Earth's
surface slip releasing a massive amount
of energy into the water this energy
travels up to the surface displacing
water and raising it above the normal
sea level but gravity pulls it back down
which makes the energy ripple outwards
horizontally thus the tsunami is born
moving it over 500 miles per hour when
it's far from shore a tsunami can be
barely detectable since it moves through
the entire depth of the water but when
it reaches shallow water something
called wave shoaling occurs because
there is less water to move through the
still massive amount of energy is
compressed the wave speed slows down
while its height rises to as much as 100
feet the word tsunami Japanese for
harbor wave comes from the fact that it
only seems to appear near the coast
if the trough of a tsunami reaches shore
first the water will withdraw farther
than normal before the wave hits which
can be misleading ly dangerous a tsunami
will not only drown people near the
coast but level buildings and trees for
a mile inland
especially in low-lying areas as if that
weren't enough the water then retreats
dragging with it the newly created
debris and anything or anyone
unfortunate enough to be caught in its
path
the 2004 Indian Ocean tsunami was one of
the deadliest natural disasters in
history killing over 200,000 people
throughout South Asia so how can we
protect ourselves against this
destructive force of nature people in
some areas have attempted to stop
tsunamis with sea walls flood gates and
channels to divert the water but these
are not always effective in 2011 a
tsunami surpassed the flood wall
protecting Japan's Fukushima power plant
causing a nuclear disaster in addition
to claiming over 18,000 lives many
scientists and policymakers are instead
focusing on early detection monitoring
underwater pressure and seismic activity
and establishing global communication
networks for quickly distributing alerts
when nature is too powerful to stop the
safest course is to get out of its way